>> Tucker: CONGRESSMAN IS ON
THE BRINK OF A SHUT DOWN
LITERALLY TOMORROW.
NANCY PELOSI WON’T ADMIT
THAT BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE
ADMITTING THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SHUTTING THE GOVERNMENT DOWN
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS REFUSE
TO LEGALIZE PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
SHE IS CLAIMING DEMOCRATS
WANT TO SHUT THE GOVERNMENT
PARTY IS TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING REPULSIVE.
THIS IS LIKE GIVING YOU BOWL
OF DOGGY DOO AND PUT A
CHERRY ON TOP AND CALL IT
CHOCOLATE SUNDAE, THIS IS
NOTHING.
>> MEANWHILE OVER ON CNN
CHRIS CUOMO SAYS THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS GUILTY
OF THE HORRIFYING SIN OF
VILIFYING PEOPLE AND
DEMANDING RIGHTS AND MONEY.
HERE HE.
>> YOU GUYS HAVE A PRETTY
INTENTIONAL EFFORT TO MAKE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AS YOU
CALL THEM MONSTERS
FICTIONALIZES THE RISK OF
TERROR THAT IS REPRESENTED
BY PEOPLE WHO COME INTO THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT’S
AGAINST THE LAW.
WE UNDERSTAND IT HAS TO
STOP.
BUT WHY MAKE THEM ALL IN TO
VILLAINS?
>> Tucker: MARK STEYN IS AN
AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST AND
ACTUAL THINKER AND HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
SO, MARC, WHEN PEOPLE LIKE
THE GUY WE JUST SHOWED PUT
AIR QUOTES AROUND THE PHRASE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
ARE YOU NOT ALLOWED TO ADMIT
THEY ARE IMGRATING
ILLEGALLY?
>> YEAH.
I THINK HE DOESN’T RECOGNIZE
THAT CATEGORY.
WHAT’S INTERESTING IS THAT
BOTH HE AND NANCY PELOSI AND
OTHERS ARE ON THAT SIDE OF
THE AISLE ARE GETTING EVER
MORE EXPLICIT IN THEIR
PREFERENCE FORRISM LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS SO-CALLED AS HE
WOULD SAY OVER AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
HE SAID, CHRIS CUOMO WENT ON
TO SAY THAT THE REAL PROBLEM
IS WHITE SUPREMACISTS IN
AMERICA.
THEY ARE THE REAL MONSTERS.
NOT THESE NICE HARD WORKING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THAT MAY BE WELL AND TRUE.
I MEAN, FOR THE PURPOSES OF
ARGUMENT LET’S SAY HE IS
RIGHT, IT’S IRRELEVANT.
THE WHITE SUPREMACISTS ARE
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE
PEOPLE WHO SHOULDN’T BE
HERE.
AND EVERY -- THE ORGANIZING
PRINCIPLE OF NATION STATES
IS THAT THEY ORGANIZE ON
BEHALF OF THEIR CITIZENS
WHETHER THEY ARE CITIZENS
ARE HERE TO CLEARED OR WHITE
SUPREMACISTS OR WHATEVER.
YOU’RE STUCK WITH THEM.
AND THIS PREFERENCE THAT
NANCY PELOSI AND CHRIS CUOMO
AND INCREASING PEOPLE HAVE
FOR ACTUALLY IMPORTING A
CLASS OF CITIZEN THAT THEY
PREFER TO THE ONES THEY ARE
STUCK WITH IS ACTUALLY VERY
REVEALING.
>> Tucker: HOW CAN YOU LEAD
A COUNTRY WHOSE POPULATION
YOU DESPISE?
I MEAN, WOULD YOU BE A GOOD
PARENT IF YOU HATED YOUR
KID?
WOULD YOU BE AN EFFECTIVE
OFFICER IF YOU DIDN’T CARE
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF YOUR
MEN?
DOESN’T THAT KIND OF PRIMA
FACIE SHOW THAT YOU ARE NOT
READY TO LEAD IF YOU DON’T
LOVE THE PEOPLE YOU ARE
LEADING?
>> NO.
I MEAN, YOU SAID WHAT ABOUT
PARENTS AND KIDS?
EVERY FAMILY, I THINK IT WAS
MALCOLM WHO SAID THAT
FRIENDS ARE GOD’S APOLOGY
FOR RELATIVES.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU PICK
YOUR FRIENDS.
YOU’RE STUCK WITH YOUR
RELATIVES.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GETTING
VERY CLOSE TO SAYING THAT
FOREIGNERS ARE GOD’S APOLOGY
FOR AMERICANS.
NANCY PELOSI HAS EXPLICITLY
THE PARENTS OF THESE
SO-CALLED DACA PEOPLE FOR
BRINGING THEM HERE
ILLEGALLY.
TO GO BACK TO WHAT YOUR
SWEDISH GUEST WAS SAYING,
YOU KNOW, WHATEVER THE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS, WHICH ARE
MINIMAL AND NOT EVENLY
DISTRIBUTED, THE CULTURAL
TRANSFORMATION, WHICH IS
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN SWEDEN,
OTHER PARTS OF EUROPE, IN
OTHER WORDS WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN ARIZONA, TOO,
THAT’S FOREVER.
IN ARIZONA A MAJORITY OF THE
GRADE SCHOOL CHILDREN NOW
ARE HISPANIC.
THAT MEANS ARIZONA’S FUTURE
IS AS AN HISPANIC SOCIETY
THAT MEANS IN EFFECT THE
BORDER HAS MOVED NORTH.
AND THE CULTURAL
TRANSFORMATION OUTWEIGHS ANY
ECONOMIC BENEFITS THAT LADY
WAS TALKING ABOUT.
>> Tucker: AT THE VERY LEAST
BEWILDERING FOR PEOPLE WHO
GREW UP HERE AND THAT’S
REAL.
I DON’T THINK HAVE YOU TO BE
ANIMATED BY HATE.
MAYBE I SHOULD HAVE SOME SAY
IN HOW MY COUNTRY EVOLVES.